iphone courage I'm Christian Sims and
inspiring up and coming I would just say
young actor and I'm going to tell you
seven reasons who I think the film
process is such a wonderful thing first
reason is the idea you get to take
somebody else's idea and be a part of it
and breathe life into that that's such a
cool thing right that's why I love it
that's the first written second reason
is you get to work with some of the most
greatest people in the industry if you
have Meyers somebody and this is the
time to learn from them to observe what
they do and actually see how they're
there they're taking the process and
actually you know surrendering to the
process and um you know you just get to
seed the essence of how they get ready
for a role or whatever it is a play or a
Samba whatever it is and it's a very
cool thing third thing is exploration
you get to explore new sites as an actor
you could explore new interesting facts
ideas you learn so much intellectually
and you get just to explore it it's
curious it's it's a very curious thing
on it's cool that's the third thing
exploration for thing is you get to
learn if you if you really think about
it you you when you're when you learn
about the fun process you start to learn
about yourself you learn some things
that are are there internally that you
might not have known which is a very
cool thing so sometimes when your infant
process you get to learn more about
yourself and what was good for you and
and that's a very good thing okay that's
the fourth fifth reason the fifth reason
is um is
I you get to make your craft better
which is always great this way you can
you actually this is when you start to
be more bold and your rose and what you
choose on how how your take on the role
so you start to pick up on gradually
it's a very subtle thing but you're
bitter you gradually pick up on new
skills and things when you when you in
the film process and learning you will
subconsciously or consciously pick up
new skills in in the industry so which
is always great it's always a great
thing to learn and grow which is also
it's just great the this is the sixth
thing now on the six thing is um it's
it's um it's learning that your films
and your entertainment and the content
and what you your you learn that your
when you're doing movies that it's it's
not about fame it's not about glitz and
glam but you can actually motivate
somebody you can not only motivate
somebody you can actually touch somebody
fulfilling and through entertainment
which is one of the greatest things you
can speak a message the way you say
things so it's a beautiful thing it's a
very beautiful thing the film process
also are we on seven thing or okay yeah
we're on a sudden thing the seven thing
is you make new new you make new new
friends not only friends but just just
great people to work with and I think
that's one of the greatest things to do
is not only admire somebody but also
become a friend of acquaintances
contemporary a colleague you know
and that's great you know you start to
enlarge a circle in the industry are the
things you pick up are you I think you
become a better human being as well so
you also become more confident in
yourself and who you are and more it's
more self-evident and that is it that's
what I love about the process um I said
I'm Christian sometimes and stay tuned
the tomb courage check out their YouTube
channel film courage f I LM film courage
on youtube check them out subscribe and
like bye